okay you guys are doing something really
interesting let's go talk to some
customers both on the federal side and
even on the commercial side right where
we have some advisors who can tell us
like is this a fit is this actually
solving a problem so
you know we have some some relationships
with folks who've left the government we
can also talk to some customers who are
in the government right now we've got
this commercial these commercial folks
we can talk to you know some cisos from
large companies and just get a feel for
how important is this to you right like
this seems like it's a real problem but
is it something anybody's going to
allocate budget for in the next year or
two years
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today i am with seth
spurgle managing partner of merlin
ventures where he is responsible for
identifying cutting-edge companies from
merlin to partner with and invest in
seth has more than 20 years of
experience building selling and
investing in software and startups most
recently seth was vice president for
infrastructure technologies at inquitel
the strategic investment firm of the us
intelligence community prior to inquitel
seth was the vice president of
engineering for thinkgeek an online
seller and manufacturer of a geeky toys
and clothing and also spent 12 years at
ibm in roles ranging from software
developer to sales manager
seth spurgle welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you for joining me thanks
for having me michael
of course where are you calling from
right now i am in my lovely basement in
bethesda maryland so just outside of
washington dc am amazing i actually i i
was born in maryland but that's that's
besides the point but i have a deep
place in my heart for today you're the
managing partner of merlin vissi
you have decades of experience in in the
high-tech field working with some
amazing companies and executive roles
and and today looking more strategically
with merlin and also with with
investments in this world and so i'm
excited to sort of just go go through
your journey and and pick and choose
something some of those moments where
you learn some things about yourself and
about and about about the world and and
how you've sort of converged into
working with merlin and and some of the
operations that you're doing today so
seth maybe take me back a little bit and
share with me a little bit about your
about your journey sure so um i mean
i've been in merlin about three years
now but before that
i
kind of jumped between a few different
uh
roles within the technology space so
start coming out of college you know was
was a a small cog in the giant ibm
machine working in their services group
uh doing you know i.t development
primarily and
you know did that for a few years and
then
you know was wasn't loving it so moved
into more of a software strategy role
and as i got more exposure to the
company and saw sort of how things were
run realized that a lot of the corporate
direction was really coming out of the
sales organization at ibm so decided to
make a shift and moved into that side of
things
um
so moved into a role selling
collaboration software
lotus notes back in the day
and some other stuff into the us
government primarily so
um
defense and intelligence agencies
and it was great i got to know the
customers really well and it was just an
amazing problem set to work with um but
eventually realized that that sales and
sales management just wasn't really
what i wanted to do with my life right i
really missed being closer to the
technology
and so after a few years of doing that i
had a friend who had been a mentor at
ibm who left a few years earlier who is
now the vp of engineering at a toy
company reach out and say hey you have
any interest in coming over here and
kind of taking over from me because i go
on and do my next thing i said yes a toy
company sounds like a nice change after
after 12 years of ibm
so um went over to a company called
thinkgeek for about two years uh it was
a company that made geeky toys and
clothing a lot of like sci-fi related
stuff uh and
you know it was it was an e-commerce
company so really running the
engineering team that was building the
platform that that ran the company
um so a bit of a trial by fire at first
right learned a ton uh and it was
awesome right i mean
being able to to have fun and learn
something new and really
just work with some great people so did
that for a couple years um and then
as that company you know ran into
problems i ended up having another
colleague from ibm reach out who is now
at inquitel which is a vc for the us
government
uh and he asks yeah what is that about
uh well you know i've read that in
nearby and i was like wow this is so
freaking cool
vc for the u.s intelligence you know
side yeah so it's a neat founding story
right so around 1999 or so
um it was primarily the cia at that
point took a look around and realized
that
whereas you know if you go back to like
the 60s and you know
you know for a while after that even the
majority of r d was really being funded
by the government and all the amazing
innovation was coming out of government
right around that you know towards the
the end of the you know
1990s they realized innovation has
shifted right it's no longer coming out
of government labs it's coming out of
silicon valley it's coming out of
startups and we're missing it all so
the cia actually uh
asked some some business leaders to come
together and create this non-profit
venture capital fund to go and find
amazing startups that they could invest
in and help bring into the the us
government so that they could have
access to this amazing technology
um so i mean that was what 22 years ago
at this point uh
and it's been growing ever since then um
but it
it's an amazing company it was a lot of
fun you know
the the cool thing about it is
the diversity of stuff that we got to do
right um because we would work with so
many different
agencies and problem sets right um
just the the team i got to be part of
was was
an awesome place to learn right like i
had a guy who had a phd in botany
sitting next to me and another guy who
founded you know battery startups right
and so i could just i could walk down
the hallway and get like phd level
discussions with any of these different
topics and learn so much on a day-to-day
basis
um so that was a great way to to really
get an introduction to venture capital
um and just learn about all the
different
types of technology out there that that
you know
we're changing the world
incredible and obviously you know doing
that with with you know doing with it in
a governmental setting as well and
having the dissonance and i'm sure that
that was quite a unique experience how
did you get to merlin from there yeah so
i was there for about five years um and
like it was it was amazing right but
after five years i started to see
some of the limits of it right the
challenge of being at a company that's
been around for 20 years is they have a
certain way of doing things right and
uh you know you can only change so much
and i i you know there were certain
things i really wanted to
to change to try right um sort of spread
my wings and have a little bit more say
in the direction of something like that
at the same time merlin which was a
company that been around for 25 years
really focusing on the federal space
i've had a lot of success working with
later stage companies right so doing
some amazing stuff with like forescout
and cyber arc and netskope
and they realize you know
given
what we do
it would be amazing if we could find
some earlier stage companies that could
that are
you know sort of at the leading edge of
technology but that have a strong
complement to the stuff we're already
doing and if we could build up our own
vc and find those companies and help
bring them into this market and really
help change you know what the government
can do so you know in a lot of ways kind
of similar to what what inquite does
right trying to find these really
innovative startups and bringing them
into the federal market
for merlin right we're much more focused
on the non-ic agencies which means we
can open up a broader aperture right we
can we can look a lot more at you know
foreign companies you know coming out of
israel and and be more successful in
actually helping them come into these
these agencies um so i had a friend that
was working at merlin and you know she
introduced me to uh the ceo and we
started talking and he sort of laid out
his vision for what he wanted to do and
and you know for me
you know after a few conversations as i
started to see what what the opportunity
was and the resources that we could
really leverage to do some amazing
things it just i it was the right time
to
to leave you know i i'd been thinking
about you know what do i want to do
after inkytel and
this came up and this was you know this
was just a golden opportunity to do
something
very and so how does your day-to-day
look like right now so um you know
so we opened up an office in israel
actually uh in january of this year
which has been amazing right it's been
great to
try to invest in israel from the us you
know we found some amazing companies but
it's it's it's a whole different
ballgame when you have somebody on the
ground there that that is going to these
you know running to these companies on a
day-to-day basis
um but i will say that it also makes a
lot more time zone challenges uh when
you've got a team in israel and then you
know i'm here in the u.s
uh so typically most of my mornings are
spent on the phone with our team in
israel or with companies in israel
talking trying to decide you know who
which of these companies are potential
fits for us
um
and then i'd say that most of the
afternoon is spent more with the the
parent company merlin cyber side of
things working with them to understand
what are the different types of needs
they're seeing across the customer set
right are there large programs coming
out that have a need for certain types
of technologies that maybe we've seen
already or maybe we should be looking
for
um you know so so it's a nice balance
right sort of saddling those two because
on the one hand i get to see the need
and on the other hand i get to see the
innovation and i can try to pair those
up
and so are you is it sort of that you're
articulating the needs and then finding
companies that are that are suiting
those needs or is it that you're open
you're open to discovering new needs
through these companies because you know
as as an investor i find a lot of times
that you know i'm being presented with
an idea for a company and all of a
sudden i'm discovering that there's this
whole new problem that i that i never
even knew existed yes
yes i mean it's certainly some of that
too right so i think you know the the
perfect day is when you know i'm sitting
in a meeting and somebody's talking
about this new program coming out of dhs
that has a need for threat hunting and
then i go happen to hop on a call you
know that day and hear about this
amazing new technology and i can run
into the next room and say you've got to
go talk to these guys but yeah
absolutely there's been some of those as
well um there's a company in our
portfolio called sepio that does some
really cool stuff that i had never even
thought of as a problem and like they
showed me a
first time we met they showed me a mouse
they found on a air gap network that had
a cellular modem inserted into it so
like you know even though the mouse is
the computer sitting on a disconnected
network somebody is remotely hopping
into it and controlling it and that just
you know that was one of those where
like that's obviously a problem that
that the us government should be
concerned about apparently is thinking
about it today but we need to help them
think about it right so those are the
sort of companies that i love the ones
that are you know it's not just we're
doing something slightly better or
slightly cheaper than someone else it's
it's we're opening up a whole new market
space and solving a problem that people
haven't even realized yet
and is that usually something that you
understand intuitively as you meet them
over one or two conversations or does
that does that require you know a really
deep in you know research and and a lot
of heavy lifting to come to this
conviction that okay this because it's a
scary thesis to come and say this
company is actually perhaps opening up a
whole new vertical for this world
yeah no it is right and it
the benefit of opening up a whole new
vertical is you know it's something that
that you know there aren't a lot of
other people doing but it also means
it's not something that people have
necessarily budgeted for yet are
thinking about yet right and it's it's a
challenge
um
so i think there's there's a
there's a balance there right um
and you know in the case of sepio
frankly we invested and we thought we
need to go sell this to the us
government today right and and it took
us a year to really educate the market
and get the company ready right and
before we could
really bring that in um
but you know there's other cases where
so but in terms of your question of like
how did how do we know that that was the
right fit that one was just one i think
i i'm probably probably more sensitive
to that because of my background within
qtel right of like knowing the sorts of
things like when i hear air gap network
and attack that
that scares the crap out of me um but
other ones are a bit more nuanced and
there it really is okay you guys are
doing something really interesting let's
go talk to some customers both on the
federal side and even on the commercial
side where we have some advisors who can
tell us like is this a fit is this
actually solving a problem so
you know we have some some relationships
with folks who've left the government we
can also talk to some customers who are
in the government right now we've got
this commercial these commercial folks
we can talk to you know some cisos from
large companies and just get a feel for
how important is this to you right like
this seems like it's a real problem but
is it something anybody's going to
allocate budget for in the next year or
two years
um
and that's actually one of the
one of the things i liked that's a big
difference between inquitel inquitel is
actually a non-profit right so
they were created by the government to
help
you know bring these startups in
and it's it's a great position to be in
but i actually kind of like the fact
that merlin as a strategic investor for
merlin cyber you know the parent company
is really
kind of very well aligned with these
startups right we want to help them sell
into the federal market because
that's that's how our parent company
makes its money right so we want to see
these startups succeed not just as an
investor but also you know as a business
partner for them
what 100
now what what happens the day after the
investment you know from your end
yeah
so you know i think one of the
the things we've been
mulling over in our mind right is
we've had some later stage investments
we've had some earlier stage investments
and you know we've learned a lot of
lessons as we've been doing this is
exactly when the right time to invest is
right because
you know if you invest
you know later stage in a company right
like let's say a b
they're pretty far along you're probably
not going to have an opportunity to
really shape the
product direction all that significantly
but they're closer to being ready for
the federal market if you invest at a
seed or you know early you know near an
a
um
it's going to be a while before they're
really ready for federal but you have a
lot more of an opportunity to really
help them
strategize on how to get there and so i
think what we're really leaning into
more now is we want to invest early in
these companies and we don't want them
to go into federal on day one right like
going into federal really requires a lot
of resources and it's typically not the
best use of a startup that's at an early
stage that hasn't really built up their
commercial attraction yet it's something
but but it's something they should be
thinking about right in terms of
hey what should what should i be
thinking about in terms of product
direction what should i be thinking
about in terms of even investors i take
in right like what are all the things
that are eventually going to bite me if
and when i want to go into the federal
market
um
so typically speaking when we invest
right we'll
we'll have an honest conversation with
them and say like are you ready for
federal or not right now no that's
that's good that's actually probably
better in a lot of these situations but
let's review your product let's talk
about the architecture let's understand
what are the things you may need to
adjust going forward
and let's you know again we're focused
on federal but we have some commercial
ties so let's introduce you where we can
right let's leverage our network of you
know advisors out of these fortune 500
companies let's you know let's leverage
our marketing team and you know sort of
review your marketing plan and see how
we can help on the commercial marketing
as you get started in the us right um
and then you know again it's it's just
that constant sort of discussion with
them to help steer them and let them
make decisions but also try to get them
um
you know just some awareness right even
if they're not ready for federal yet we
should be starting that discussion
especially when it's a category defining
company like we talked about where
nobody's even thinking about this yet we
need to be saying how do we get you in
front of people who will be making that
decision in a year or two when you're
ready for the federal market so they
know that this is a problem they need to
be thinking about so you know helping
them in terms of events and you know
speaking slots and things like that as
well
even though they may not have a product
that's ready to sell into the federal
market today
i think that i think that makes a lot of
sense if you look back now you know sort
of at your childhood you know middle
school elementary school what really
sparked your curiosity what really you
know what really fascinated you as a kid
yeah so i mean i have to guess that that
given the type of people you interview
you get this answer a lot but i mean i i
was fascinated by computers as you know
as long as i can remember right so i
remember
i guess it i i
i had to look it up to see what year
this got discontinued but um the ti 99
4a which was an early you know personal
computer i remember it got it it got
discontinued in 1984 so they were dirt
cheap and my dad picked one up for me
and i was i would have been seven at the
time and i mean that was just the most
amazing thing i've ever seen right i
could play games on it i could i mean
that was pretty much all i could do at
age seven at that point on that thing
right but um you know my dad was taking
he was actually going to graduate school
at the time uh and learning you know
some programming and so he would like
help me you know hey figure out how to
play with it but also he would like
write games for me and and you know
really just sort of
um
helped me kind of spark the interest in
that i'd always thought like electronics
in general were cool but
this was my first you know actual
computer where i could do stuff you know
write my own basic programs and just
play with it and from there it just kept
growing right so
um
a few years later one of our neighbors
gave me his old handy hand-me-down uh
atari computer atari actually made
computers not just game systems but they
had computers as well an 800 xl um
and so that one was a little more
powerful he also gave me a beatable
printer that that wouldn't print any
punctuation so i started i had terrible
handwriting as a kid but i started
typing up all my school reports and then
i going after the fact and take a pen
and put all the periods and commas
because the printer wouldn't print them
um
and then i think you know the really big
thing was uh it would have been
early 90s you know probably
sophomore year in high school or so
uh
we got a computer but
um my mother was like a local high
school librarian and so i knew a bunch
of librarians in the area and the the
library in our town
started a pilot internet system that you
could get access to and so i got
connected to that
and it was all text based it was you
know i guess we had links as a web
browser you know a text-based web
browser but it was primarily like gopher
and all these other old protocols and i
just it was the most amazing thing for
me right like that just opened up a
whole new world i remember
my first day playing with it and i you
know i i was clicking around on gopher
and i clicked something and it connected
me to something in another country i was
like holy crap they're gonna get you
know be all pissed about the long
distance fees and everything else before
i realized how the internet actually
worked
um so yeah i mean that that was that was
something that you know just kept my
interest from from age seven up until
until now i've you know loved just
playing with technology and and you know
seeing what i could do with it
i love it and and if you look today at
your daily work what is something that
really inspires you i mean i think going
back to the conversation we were having
about the type of people i like to work
with right it's people who can teach me
things right you know
working you know with people that that
have different backgrounds are in
different fields and
you know can teach me something i had no
knowledge about that i love and that's
why you know not just co-workers but
that's why i love the the venture space
right like working with startups where
you've got people who have amazing ideas
and have turned it into a product right
have turned it into something real
to me that's just you know that's so
special and
again
i like the fact that they can teach me
what they're doing right because frankly
the best founders are the ones who can
explain what they're doing in a way that
i can understand
um
and help make me a little bit smarter
uh
so to me that's that's always been
exciting
i love it and if you had to choose a few
words to describe yourself what would
they be
so let's see so i i one of my old
co-workers made me take a personality
test recently and i apparently came up
as as one of the primary traits was
loyalty so we'll start with that but i
think
you know pragmatism you know pragmatic
is has always been a way of how i've
looked at problems right i want to do
the best possible thing that we can do
but but i also want to do something that
that is actually going to work in the
real world and you know get stuff done
um and then i guess you know there's
probably
mischievous that's always you know i
like to have fun with people as well and
uh i guess my wife might call it
annoying but i like to say mischievous
seth sen thank you so much for these 20
minutes i really really appreciate it
this was wonderful thank you thank you
very much for sharing with me your
journey and i really really enjoyed it
stay safe and stay healthy me too
thank you
thank you bye